foreign
[Music]
period
since I'm parked in the forest
I'm not getting a whole lot of solar
power but I can just heat up water using
the jet boat outside and save a little
bit of energy so that's what I'm gonna
do
foreign
[Music]
we can talk about the weather
we can talk about what they play on TV
as long as we're together
[Music]
we could talk about the weather
on every continent into the global world
we live in today
not with this process of expansion and
unification all cultures to a few large
cultures and finally to see the rise of
monotheism and the decline dualism
thank you
[Music]
I never know what to say when I put the
camera at myself it's so awkward I don't
know if you guys have been around my
channel for a little bit then you know
usually my videos are kind of a
patchwork of different days different
places and I I don't film in a linear
fashion I find that I end up filming
all kinds of b-roll and scenes when I'm
in a place but then I have no context or
any moments where I'm just like talking
to you guys and kind of explaining
what's going on I I might actually be in
different states or different places
with different people doing different
things when it comes time to create a
video I don't even know if I can
quantify it honestly I
if I had to guess probably like 20 hours
of footage that I have to go through
through four five different cameras that
I use
um my R5 is my primary but I also use
two different iPhones and the DJI action
and my drone so going through all of
those and trying to piece them together
and see like oh what can I pull from
here what can I pull from there is the
quality of this footage any better than
this and whatnot it can be it's just
really time consuming and I love the
creative process and I love putting
videos together especially when you
combine the element of Music and Sound
but I find that so much of my time is
lost in the weeds of just organizing
ideally I just like to put stuff out
more often which means I don't want to
say the quality is going to suffer but
it might just be different you know and
I just want to start experimenting with
that a lot of you are interested in
seeing the nitty-gritty unfiltered raw
day-to-day van life and totally get that
like that makes sense that you would
want to see that especially if you're
considering this lifestyle I mean I
could just take my iPhone with a selfie
stick and I could strap a GoPro to my
head and I could film and show you what
my life is really like and maybe some of
you guys would really like that I
wouldn't though it would be so boring I
mean my life is like does anyone else's
life I just live in a van
[Music]
but also what I'm doing just isn't
working because it leaves me feeling
constantly behind
yesterday I nearly spit out my coffee
watching a YouTube video that mentioned
the upcoming spring season because I
still haven't even started editing my
snowy content and for a minute I
actually considered hiring an editor
but the truth is I can't imagine dumping
a mountain of incohesive footage onto
someone and asking them to make sense of
it
it's hard enough for me and I was there
[Music]
besides editing my own work helps me
understand where I can improve with
filming and storytelling
and that's my real goal in having this
YouTube channel
my dream job is to be a professional
high-end organizer and my other dream
job if I could do both uh would be to
make music videos for some of my
favorite artists like Ben Howard or
Gregory Alan isakov like I love their
music their music inspires me so much
out on the road and when I go out to
Nature and I would love to pair those
scenes that I've seen out on the road
with their music and I would love to do
that professionally as well so I have a
lot a lot a lot to learn that's just a
little bit of a rant on my creative
process and maybe what to expect moving
forward which is just like maybe have no
expectations at all because I'm just
going to be experimenting with what
feels right
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
I spent a lot of time biking this fall
just trying to give my ankle a rest
thank you
truthfully I'd prefer to have a mountain
bike
but my bike has been the easiest storage
wise since I haven't needed to install a
rack or anything
so here's how I have the bike set up now
um so there's still plenty of space to
walk through here and
that's because I took this pedal off
which is pretty easy to take on and off
whenever I want to go riding and then I
also put the seat down I also put this
little sock here on the metal part so
that when I open my fridge doesn't hit
this is the tightest spot here and as
you can see I also move my suitcase up
here so this has become like a very busy
section of the van but
um moving the suitcase allowed me to fit
the stand-up paddle board in the back
because the stand-up paddle board really
wouldn't fit anywhere else in the
suitcase I have backpacks stacked
together and then I have this backpack
with another backpack stacked in so it's
like stacks on Stacks the bike is I mean
it's really not that much in the way I
have it bungeed here so it's super solid
like barely moves at all and when I want
to use the heater I just unbungie it and
just turn it out at an angle here and
then I have the heater vent pointing
this way I also have this little towel
under here because you can see this
metal base I don't want to scratch the
floors up although the floors are
already really scratched but that kind
of helps when I want to take it out I
just remove this battery and the lock
because those are both pretty heavy so
that reduces the overall weight and then
I'll just lift it up a little bit and
roll it out on the wheel and then
just that last little push down onto the
ground is pretty much all to get the
bike out and then yeah putting it back
in is pretty much the same but I tried
so many different options I tried
turning these handlebars down I tried
actually putting it in the front seat
which was just it almost worked it
almost worked this swivel chair
it can move like if I take a a sharp
turn
I don't have access to the front cab
which is a little bit of a safety issue
and it's going to trigger the seat belt
alarm which I could
Buckle it but
I was counting on the Buckle to actually
hold it in place along with some bungee
cords so
it's too bad I don't think this is a
very practical solution it did get me
thinking of how much extra space I would
have if I didn't have this passenger
seat at all because the passenger seat
has a swivel package on it but I never
use it because obviously I have so much
stuff built around it if I just got rid
of it and like built some kind of I'm
thinking like maybe a stand-up cabinet
where I could have
hanging clothes or something I don't
know just an idea but I guess
technically legally
I don't think I'd be able to have
passengers in the van ever because they
wouldn't have a seat belt but anyway
just dreaming of new ideas this is my
new outdoor table and the moon shade and
they're both held in with magnets here
so they're not like flying all over the
place when I'm driving
um this is going to go up top pretty
soon I got a new shoe bin
just so that they're more accessible
rather than having them all stored in
the back
and uh yeah I think that's pretty much
it
is
[Applause]
[Music]
one thing I really love about living on
the road is you just never know who
you'll run into
while I was out writing one day I came
across my friend Mike who just happened
to be camped One Forest Road over
we met up a few times over the next week
usually after finishing up our work days
to just bike around and catch sunsets
I don't think I'll ever get over just
how incredible it is to go from Full
office mode to full adventure mode by
just stepping outside my door
I'm pretty sure that's a feeling that
we'll never get old
ER
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
previously on the handmaid's tale for
those who are truly righteous he
sometimes sends a refuge